[Music]
welcome to cbs mornings if you grew up
in my house it would be buy yourself
something nice and put the rest of it in
savings
no that's no fun have a great
appreciation for savings accounts
welcome to cbs news we're going to begin
with this we've got a possible deal on
the debt limit that could avoid an
economic crisis we'll get to that in
just a second but we begin with breaking
news overnight from texas on the state's
controversial abortion law a federal
judge is putting the measure on hold
calling it unconstitutional
jan crawford is following that story jan
good morning to you well good morning
y'all so the reaction among biden
administration officials abortion rights
advocates was relief the judge's
decision stems from a justice department
lawsuit against texas last month just
days after sba went into effect the law
outlies abortions once embryonic
activity is detected which is usually
around six weeks and that can be before
some women even know they're pregnant
and it allows private citizens to
enforce it by bringing civil lawsuits
against anyone who helps a woman get an
abortion after that with fines starting
at ten thousand dollars but in a
strongly worded 113 page ruling judge
robert pittman said the law was
blatantly unconstitutional from the
moment sba went to effect women have
been unlawfully prevented from
exercising control over their lives and
this court will not sanction one more
day of this offensive deprivation of
such an important right now in a
statement the bind administration
cautioned that the fight has only just
begun texas of course will appeal and
the supreme court is taking up that
mississippi abortion ban in december
that is likely going to determine not
only the fate of this law in texas but
other states as well
nate
we will keep an eye on that jan thank
you